Hey youtubers it's Charlie, since we just
ended season 4 and a lot of you requested
more history stuff from the books I thought
would be fun to talk about Aegon Targaryen
the first, Aegon the Conqueror.
So far in the books and on the show he's the
most famous member of their house to ever
live.
Daenerys right now is kind of polarizing,
love her or hate her, her destiny isn't fully
written yet.
So after all the books are done she might
become the most famous member of house Targaryen.
If you're just finding me for the first time
I'm doing game of thrones bonus videos in
the off season every Sunday.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
A lot of times the topics I pick are things
that you guys suggest in the comments.
So if there's something you want to learn
more about just let me know.
I'm also doing a special giveaway I'll explain
at the end of this video.
So who is Aegon the 1st and why is he so much
more important than the other thousands of
Targaryen's that followed him?
The answer is he's largely associated with
The War Of Conquest, that's a span of time
when Aegon gave the Andal rulers of Westeros
an ultimatum.
Bend the knee or you get the dragons.
That's why he's known as Aegon the Conqueror.
He conquered the Six Kingdoms and eventually
Dorne was brought in too.
The iron throne is made from thousands of
melted down swords of the andals he defeated.
On the show the throne is way smaller, so
it's harder to tell.
Originally George RR Martin described the
Iron Throne as being this big.
It's so huge because that's a lot of swords.
It's just not practical for television.
That's the cliff's notes.
But George RR Martin has recently published
a lot more details about Aegon the first's
personal history, as well as their early days
in the Seven Kingdoms right after they fled
the Valyrian Freehold up to the day he declared
war on the Andals.
So starting off, about 12 years before the
Doom of Valyria in 114 BC, Before Conquest,
Aenar Targaryen the head of the house at the
time, moved everything of theirs to Dragonstone
after one of his daughters Daenys had a vision
of the Doom.
When I say everything, he took all their dragons,
wealth and servants.
If you've ever thought about events repeating
themselves in Song of Ice and Fire, the eastern
continent around the Valyrian Freehold was
known as the land of the Long Summer before
the Doom.
Right now on the show, the Long Summer is
just now ending.
That's why you keep hearing, Winter is Coming.
It's a metaphor for the end of prosperity.
Unlike the Targaryen's very few characters
are fleeing the current Lands of Summer, in
this case being Westeros.
Dragonstone had up to that point been the
western most outpost of the Valyrian Freehold
and had served as a heavily defensible point
where the Dragonlords of Valyria could control
Trade around Blackwater bay.
But now it became the permanent and only home
of the Targaryens.
Five generations passed after the Doom before
Aegon the Conqueror was born, so the House
lived at Dragonstone for about a 100 years
before he came along.
His birth date is recorded as 27 BC, so he
wasn't quite 30 before he began the War of
Conquest.
He was a middle child, his older sister was
Visenya and his younger sister was Rhaenys.
Even though it was customary to marry brother
to sister in Old Valyria, Aegon supposedly
also married his younger sister out of Lust
and the older one out of responsibility.
At the time of Aegon's birth, they only had
3 dragons.
When they fled from Valyria to dragonstone,
they had 5, but only Balerion the Black Dread
survived the trip.
So far none of the literature explains why
the other four died.
Only that Balerion survived.
In the years between their landing and Aegon's
birth, two more dragons had hatched, Vhagar
and Meraxes.
Aegon did spend time visiting Westeros before
the conquest and if you've seen that epic
table Stannis uses at Dragonstone, the one
carved in a perfect topographical map of the
Seven Kingdoms.
Aegon was the one who had that carved.
It's probably one of the most famous non-magical
antiques in the seven kingdoms next to the
Iron Throne itself.
The start of the War of Conquest came when
Argilac the Arrogant, ruler in the Stormlands
asked Aegon for help in suppressing Harren
the Black, ruler of everything up north of
the Stormlands.
As you can imagine, he was building Harrenhal.
Supposedly it was so big it took over 40 years
to complete.
Harren had been slowly taking land from the
Argilac over the years until he contacted
Aegon and offered him his daughter in marriage
and pretty much all of their land.
Aegon was already married to his sisters so
he turned down the proposal and countered
by offering to help in exchange for all the
land and the marriage of Argilac's daughter
to Aegon's childhood friend Orys Baratheon.
Now you're starting to see where House Baratheon
came from.
They were born or elevated to Lordship during
the War of Conquest.
After Arglic threw Aegon's proposal back in
his face, he pulled a Reek thing where he
sent pieces of Aegon's messenger back to him
in a box.
Aegon decided to make war on all the andal
kings.
The way the calendars work on the show right
now, BC Before Conquest and AL after landing
refer to when he first landed right here at
the black rush.
The place where he would eventually build
King's Landing.
That's generally regarded as the start date
of the War, it took about two full years to
completely subdue 6 of the kingdoms, not including
Dorne.
The Kings that he defeated included Torrhen
Stark, King in the North.
Ronnel Arryn, King of the Vale, his mother
was his regent like Cersei did for Joffrey
because he was a young boy, Harren Hoare,
King of the Iron Islands and the Riverlands.
Lorren Lannister, King of the Westerlands,
Mern IX Gardener, King of the Reach and Argilac
Durrendon, King of the Stormlands
He didn't just march right in and defeat everyone
with sustaining heavy losses.
That's why the war took so long, and even
then he couldn't defeat the Martells in Dorne.
By the end of the war some of the kings had
honorably bent the knee like the Starks and
the Arryns and the rest were smashed or melted
in battle, big dragons remember.
I don't think they mentioned it on the show,
but the Kings who submitted and joined forces
with Aegon didn't get their swords melted
down into the Iron Throne.
The Starks were one of those Houses.
So there is no Stark sword inside the Iron
Throne.
However, as of Season 4 Episode 1, Tywin Lannister
melted down Ned Stark's valyrian blade Ice.
Because he was silent during that scene it's
hard to tell if he was thinking about that
historical fact.
That seems like something Tywin would think
about even though it happened hundreds of
years before he was born.
Actually the Lannisters defeat during the
War of Conquest was really cool.
Towards the end of the war before he marched
on Dorne, Aegon met the Lannisters and the
Gardeners in battle, they had formed an alliance.
Instead of starting an all out ground assault,
Aegon had the dragons set the whole field
of grass on fire, where the enemy army was.
They flipped their shit and surrendered.
It's a good example of sophisticated use of
dragons in battle.
Rather than have the dragons crush everyone
one by one, they just turned the heat up in
the oven.
Much more efficient.
Right now on the show I don't think Daenerys
has the dragonlore to attempt something like
this, plus in the desert all the land has
already been burnt to a crisp.
Aegon was eventually confirmed as King of
the Seven Kingdoms in Oldtown, but he built
a new city, King's Landing around his fort
overlooking Blackwater Bay.
It was called Aegonfort, but eventually Aegon
moved back to dragonstone while the city continued
to be built and a better castle which would
become the Red Keep.
The Red Keep is the name of the whole castle,
including Maegor's Holdfast, the Queen's Ballroom,
the Maidenvault, the White Sword Tower, the
Great Hall, Traitor's Walk and four different
levels of dungeons all the way down to the
Black Cells.
That's the lowest area of the Dungeons where
Tyrion was when Jaime helped him escape in
the finale.
We've seen most of the other areas on the
show.
The White Sword Tower is where the Kingsguard
stay, that was where Jaime and Cersei were
humping their brains out in the finale.
Aegon died about 37 years after his conquest,
so he would have been in his mid 60s.
We don't know anything about how he died,
but when his son Aenys the first took the
throne the church of the seven flipped out
because it was a son born out of incest.
It led to the first Faith Militant Uprising.
That's the army of the church, it's just like
a regular army, they just take orders from
the church.
Aenys mother was Rhaenys, Aegon's younger
sister.
He was about 30 when he took the throne.
But that's a somewhat abridged version of
Aegon the conqueror's history.
George RR Martin is publishing a book called
World of Ice and Fire this fall, so hopefully
that will have new historical information
to add to all this.
I'm not planning on doing a Q&A for this video
just because Teen Wolf is starting tomorrow
night and I'm doing videos for it.
But I am going to start a new Game of Thrones
Giveaway.
I'm going to be giving away copies of the
books to one person per Game of Thrones video.
I'll just be picking winners randomly from
the comments.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
It's starting with this video right here.
I'll announce who the winner is when I post
my next game of thrones video next Sunday.
I'll do that for the next 6 or seven weeks
and see how it goes.
The prize will just be your choice of one
of the books.
Either Kindle edition or paperback.
It's open to international people too so no
worries.
Feel free to ask me any questions about Aegon
or the giveaway.
Right now click here for my top 10 moments
from season 4 and click here for my season
5 predictions.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!